We had the very unfortunate situation of having
a guest cancel on us last minute.
And so we are going to pick up on a few phone
calls and see what's on people's, you can
call in at (617) 830-4750. Let's go to our
caller from the two six zero color from two
six zero. What's your name? Where are you
calling from?
Hi, this is Joanna. Um, I have, um, family
member who is a libertarian and um, can you,
can you hear me okay. Okay. Um, so I like
really want Medicare for all and um, I talk
about it a lot with them and um, they, their
argument is like, well why would you want
to give the government even more control?
Um, cause they're, they want small government.
Um, and the only thing like I can come up
with is like, well, you know, if Congress
had to have the same, you know, health care
that we did, they'd make sure that it was
like awesome, but I didn't know like what
else I could tell them to like get them onboard
with Medicare for all.
Yeah. I mean listen, you're probably not going
to be able to get them on board with Medicare
for all. I think that the extreme libertarian
position is one of the hardest ones to kind
of bring over to the side of wanting the government
to do things because they see the government
stepping out as good at it. They see the government
not being involved as virtuous regardless
of the outcome. Even if what the free market
ends up putting together is inferior in some
way. They don't want the government involved
and believe the government can't do anything.
The reality is that um, the government is
not objective really bad at doing things.
It the, the problem is that we often have
a disagreement as to what different people
believe our tax money should go to and we
end up having too much money going to certain
things like the military, the Pentagon, defense
weapons, military industrial complex, et cetera,
and not enough going towards things like healthcare.
Now as far as costs goes, other countries
where the government is more involved in healthcare,
spend less per person and have better outcomes.
So if their concern is that they don't think
the government would do a good job, there's
many counter examples that could be given.
If their concern is that it's going to cost
too much, well then you can talk to them about
the cost programs that are, are very reasonable
in terms of what something like this would
cost. If they simply ideologically don't want
the government doing stuff that's going to
be a, you're going to hit a brick wall there.
I don't know what you could say.
Ooh,
gotcha. Yeah, that's helpful. Um, cause they,
you know, they obviously, you know, believe
the government is corrupt. Um, and they agree
with me that healthcare should not be for
profit. Um, and so I'm like well that's why
you don't want like private companies in charge
of healthcare because their whole goal is
to generate profit as much profit as possible.
Yeah. I mean, and most healthcare companies,
the industry in the U S is regulated in a
way that actually sort of limits the percentage
that health insurance companies can profit.
But just because we're talking about it, there
are other systems, like for example, one where
the government, you still have non-government
insurance companies, they have to be nonprofit
companies and they are heavily regulated by
the government. And the government still act
sometimes as a payer, like there's all sorts
of different plans. You can look at what France
does. Germany, Switzerland, there's lots of
different ideas. But again, if it's just an
ideological barrier, it can be tough to talk
to libertarians.
Hmm.
All right. Thank you so much. I appreciate
it.
All right, Joanna, I appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.